The Past, Present and Future of JavaScript
Date and Time APIs
Matt Johnson
[Applause]
MATT: Just a second here.
Okay.
So everybody hear me all right?
I'm Matt, I work on Moment.js.
Everybody in the room use Moment.js?
A few people, yes?
Lots of people, pretty much everybody.
We have been lucky enough to become one of
the premier libraries for JavaScript.
We didn't set out to do that.
It would have been nice if JavaScript date
was good from the beginning so that's kind
of what I want to talk to you about today,
how did we get here, what can you do today,
are there other good options other than Moment.js,
I think there are, and what are we going to
do in the future?
So I work at Microsoft, a site reliability
engineer which means I don't do a lot of JavaScript
in the daytime.
I have been a JavaScript developer for quite
had a while though, also a .NET developer.
I mainly focus on the domain of date and time
so if you ever have questions about time zone,
daylight saving time, how to schedule things,
any of those sorts of topics, you can probably
find me on Stack Overflow, that's usually
where I hang out.
I also have a lot of open source daytime related
libraries and if you've got daytime bugs on
your projects I may have jumped in and fixed
it.
That's what I do.
And I like cheese, because everybody likes
cheese.
So what is a date, let's talk about dates.
I think a date looks like this January 1st.
Everybody agree with me that's a date?
Yes, I think that's a date.
But that gets us into problems with JavaScript.
If we take a look at this little demo that
I made here, this is literally all I have,
a HTML5 date input type, okay, and all I am
going to do with that is just give you the
output.
I am going to feed that into the value of
an object and I am going to say to date string.
Let's say I was born today, okay, what happened
here?
I picked May 7th but I got May 6th.
Does anybody ever run into this problem with
the date object?
This is one of the things that people yell
and scream about the date object.
What's going on here?
What's going on here is that I'm from the
United States and I haven't adjusted this
computer's time zone to be east of the UTC
line, it's still west of it, so if you happen
to be that negative offset from UTC you will
find that JavaScript will throw your dates
off by one, and this happens because the specification
originally wasn't clear about what to do when
you only have a date.
It just said: if I've got some value what
I don't know the offset then the offset must
be UTC.
Well, what's an UTC day?
From UTC midnight to UTC the end of midnight
- the only people that I know of that are
always on an UTC day are mostly in Iceland.
Iceland is on GMT year round.
Even in Greenwich where they draw the Greenwich
mean line, that's not on UTC all the time.
They are UTC plus one right now for British
Summer Time so there's a discrepancy in the
last two forms here between this specification
which is where we get all of our date and
time standards from and the other specification.
As you can see the third item on there is
a date and a time and originally it was said
that should be UTC but they later corrected
it to be local so fortunately for date and
times we now know all modern browsers will
be on local time but for date forms they got
stuck with UTC and really this comes down
to web reality.
We wanted to change it, the implementers all
wanted to change it but when Chrome tried
there were so many lash backs within a small
window that they had to revert so the script
now only says four date only forms they are
UTC and that's because that's the reality
of the web since the early days of the Internet.
But a date - what is a date?
It's not [audio problem] in JavaScript it's
not, it's a time stamp.
It's the number of seconds since - the number
of milliseconds since - you can't have.
We lost display here.
Hold on.
There we go, so we can't have just the date
represented in terms of milliseconds.
You all should probably know this but not
every day is a whole number of 24 hours exactly
and the days that aren't are random all around
the world because of time zones.
When we are in standard time and then we switch
to summertime or we call it daylight time
in some parts of the world, we might have
a 23 or 25-hour local day depending on which
way we are transitioning.
If you live on this small island called Lord
Howe Island they only switch by half an hour
so you will have a 23.5-hour day, or a 24.5-hour
day, so you can't just measure a date in terms
of milliseconds.
It's the wrong type.
I like to call it a datish.
We have the falsey, truthy, it's a datish.
There's this wonderful quote: off by one and
naming thins, cash validation doesn't apply
here.
I usually throw time zones into the mix of
things that are hard in computer science so
one wonders what were they thinking, why did
they do this?
I have to go back to this, Brendan and I,
one of the inventors of JavaScript called
Live Script back then, they had very little
time to do this and they were told just make
it look like Java, and he has told us many
times, and there's a couple of blog posts.
Actually it was Ken Smith, not Brendan, Ken
of net scape, took the utility code from Java
in the implementation and translated into
the implementation for the early days to JavaScript.
This is what that looked like.
Everybody thinks that it all happened all
at once but if you look at the dates you can
see that when they developed it Java was in
beta.
Nobody had used this thing.
They just said this is how Java does dates
so this is how JavaScript will do dates and
by the time Java 1.0 came out the JavaScript
prototype was set in stone and then when Java
1.1 came out we deprecated almost all the
functionality, moving it off to something
called Java calendar so we are stuck with
a model that was fundamentally broken and
found pretty early on, and we never did anything
about.
We published ECMAScript 1.0 afterwards and
adjusted that and that's just what we have
today, so there's a lot of things that are
wrong besides just the date parsing.
I showed you how when you parse the date you
can be off by one but look at this code.
Can anybody guess what this result?
This looks reasonable.
A lot of people would write something like
this.
Just think in your mind what you might think
it is.
I look at that and say: well, it's December
31st and I'm adding a month so it must be
January 31st, is the result.
>> [off mic]
MATT: We end up at March 2nd.
Only when I run this code from this time zone
in Berlin.
Notice in terms of time we did something implicit
which
converted it from local to UTC time and gave
me an UTC-based time stamp so not only do
I end up on March 2nd, because I actually
started on November 31st, which doesn't exist,
so I started - sorry, on January 31st.
So I went to February 31st, which doesn't
exist, so I went into March, and then I went
back an hour for UTC.
So there's a lot of things wrong with this.
The other thing that it highlights is that
data is mutable.
Notice how I've added a month?
I had on get the month and then increment
it and then rely on this bubbling functionality
in order to move from one month to the next.
These are really difficult concepts, especially
for a beginner developer.
Date in almost any other language is a value
type, it's immutable.
It doesn't change once you create it.
If you add a month, you have a specific method;
add a month and you get back the one with
the month added.
The other thing we have wrong with date is
notice nowhere here did I say what time I
was starting, I just started it in local time
so the only thing it supports is the local
time that the environment is running on and
UTC.
Well, that's really bad if you are a Node
developer because nobody cares about the times
going on your server.
You really shouldn't care about times going
on your server anyway.
Okay, this one I love, strings should be interchangeable
in most JavaScript things, we have string
0, regular 0, 00, or 000.
Does anybody think this should give the same
results, whatever they might be?
They kind of should be the same defaults.
I will give you a hint, they are in descending
order here.
Every one of those things is going to give
you something different, and so the first
one is because when you only parse a number
as a string it's treated as a year, so year
2000, and anything that is parsed as a number
is treated as a time stamp so we are right
at the epoch there.
Notice it's not midnight there, it's 11.00am
so not even the same time.
1.00am.
1900 is because if you pass a year from 0
to 99 JavaScript data treats that as 1900
to avoid Y2K problems but as soon as you go
to 100 that is year 100 so they are not even
sequential in terms of parameters.
And 09 just because of the overflow situation
I showed you before, we have no such thing
as the easier day of the month so it just
goes back one day.
What do we do with this?
We saw Java came out with Joda-Time.
If you are a Java developer you should be
familiar with it.
It is the base for 3010 which made its way
onto Java 8 so you should be using Java 8
with the time package with a few tweaks to
make it better.
There is alternate one that is also very good
called Time4J and they take a little different
philosophy between the two.
We also had to address this with libraries.
Really early on there was a date JS library
and I don't recommend you use that today but
Sugar and Moment came on the scene in 2011
and Sugar is still pretty good if you want
to do something called natural language parsing,
like if you have a string that says: what
time is it three days and two months from
now and it's actually spelt out as a string,
Sugar will parse that and try to make a good
guess at it.
But most people are using Moment.
Moment does about 90% of the things you would
want to do with date and time.
Maybe even 99%.
But Moment isn't the only thing out there.
There are people working on a port of the
Joda-Time standard into JavaScript, that's
the js-joda library and I think JS is pretty
awesome.
There is also this thing called date functions
which has got a lot of notoriety lately, which
says instead of a very large JavaScript object
if all you need to do is add a month, let's
just add a month.
So you pull in individual functions for different
things, so I am going to show you those libraries.
Moment I saw everybody is familiar with.
We are very specific when we do our parsing.
We don't make that assumption that said: I
can tell you what you want.
No, I can't always tell what you want, sometimes
you have to tell me so if you give me a string
with no context and you don't tell me what
it is then I will assume it's local time because
that's what the date object does.
If you give me a string with no context and
tell me you want it as UTC then I will assume
it is UTC and we have time zone support through
the Moment time grown library that imports
the database that pretty much all modern computing
uses.
Moment's API is fluid and intentional so we
can do something liked and 200 days and then
format that.
I can tell exactly what my input style should
be so there's no confusion on whether that's
July 5th or May 7th, because I'm telling you
explicitly that it's day, month, year format.
The only problem that we have lately with
Moment is it is still a mutable API and that's
because when it was originally developed it
was built using the JavaScript date object
as its basis so notice I clone the Moment
here before I start adding to it.
If I didn't do that, it wouldn't just output
the same string here but would also change
the value of this M variable, so it's important
when you are working with Moment that you
realise it does mutate the object as you work
through its API.
That's something we are considering from OF3O.
There's some progress on that so hopeful we
will have a Moment 30 with immutable API.
You can validate simple dates.
It does what it says it does and it does it
pretty good.
Let's look at this date functions library
I mentioned.
It's very lightweight and modular, and the
intent is every single function is its own
module so you only pull on the ones you need.
If all I need is something that will format
a string and add some days then I just import
those to functions.
It uses date objects as I was saying so I
create a date object, I format it, I get the
output.
Again, remember that JavaScript date object
has zero base months so it looks like I'm
parsing January 1st but it is not, it is February
1st so the string says February 1st.
This adds days as it says, so it doesn't add
a value.
So if you want immutable functions check out
date functions.
Js-joda is also really good, it also has an
immutable API, it models separation of concerns
very well so we have a different object which
is a local date and local in this context
doesn't mean local to the computer; it means
not - it means could be local anywhere.
It means somebody is local.
And that's just terminology that has been
borrowed over from the ISO8601 standard into
Java and now up into js-joda so you may see
that a few places.
When we work with this API, we don't have
to have the API guess what we want; we tell
it specifically what we want.
We say: here is a date, get the start of the
day, I wants that for Berlin and then I want
to know the equivalent time in the computer's
local time or in UTC.
I can do these things very easily.
The start of day function is a really interesting
concept also.
Keep in mind that not every day starts right
at midnight so a start of day isn't just snap
to midnight and truncate off data.
If you are in Brazil or a few other places
around the world when they start daylight
saving time they go from 11.5959 of the night
before up to 0100, so you have to have those
rules in your data to know that the start
of day is not necessarily midnight.
And Joda-Time is also immutable, so we have
D1 and D2 here being different objects, the
same as I showed you before.
So what are we going to do?
How are we going to get out of this mess where
we don't have to use libraries or deal with
an API that is broken.
I think we should fix it, do you think we
should fix it?
So Moment.js is a JavaScript Foundation member,
Maddie and Brian Terlson are helping with
this and we've reached stage 1 which means
we have general approval of the committee
to think about how to do a new date API.
We have a general idea about what we want
but it is not locked in so definitely come
take a look and give your opinions, we will
take issues on GitHub, we will take poll requests,
any way you want to talk to us or come find
Maggie after the talk here.
Generally we want to make date better.
We want to learn from the APIs that have come
before us, not just in JavaScript but in other
languages, we want to be comfortable for everybody
who uses JavaScript so it needs to be idiomatic,
not to bring in a whole load of Java cruft
and other things that don't apply, at least
not today, and we are going to do the 1 base
months, not the 0 base months.
I will put my foot down on that one.
Possible ideas: it might look like Moment,
or Joda-Time or Time4J, it might be that we
provide functionality so that platforms can
do what they need to do in a smaller and more
direct way but we don't know yet, so help
us figure it out.
Here are some examples, and you can see we
have this zone date time object that's a very
joda-like object but I'm not doing a lot of
object construction to get the time zone.
I'm just parsing them along as strings.
If I want to add time, I might do something
like add to, and that's very Moment-like.
What else might we be able to do?
This is actually a very complex problem if
you are in a scheduling environment.
If I need to run an event at the same time
every day but it's in the user's local day,
so this is a starting point and then I say
I want the next four occurrences but I'm crossing
a daylight saving time transition so 8.00am
every day even when the offset in the Pacific
time zone changes from minus 8 to minus 7
you can see here the UTC output has changed
also so I cannot schedule in UTC time, I need
to schedule in local time and doing that without
a library is really, really hard with the
JavaScript object.
Most people will just say: plus 24, times
60, times 60, times whatever to get the next
instant but then you will find you're running
at 7.00 or 9.00am and they will be off by
one.
It would look something like this.
If you think this looks awful and you have
a better idea, come talk to us.
If you think this is great, let us know, and
that's really all I've got so please give
your feedback.
If you have other questions, come find me
afterwards, or you can always post on Stack
Overflow.
If you just tag it with date time or time
zone, I will find it probably.
Lots of other people as well, and I have a
six-hour course on fundamentals on Pluralsight
if you really want on dive in, so thank you
very much.
[Applause]
>> Thank you so much for that.
That was fantastic.
We are running a little ahead of time so I
think maybe we've got time for a question
or two, if you want to handle that?
Anyone has any questions, stick your hand
up.
MATT: Question?
>> Questions from anybody?
MATT: No.
Okay.
>> Thank you so much, I honestly learned so,
so much from that.